Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and a lot of
you requested I do a video for the Batman
vs Superman comic con trailer so that’s
what this video will be. I know a lot of you
Deadpool people were way more excited about
that clip and everyone assumes Marvel is the
big event of the weekend. But just looking
at the raw number of mentions on social media.
Batman vs Superman was the most talked about
thing this weekend. And it wasn’t even a
trailer. It was a super short clip without
any dialogue.
But in case you're just finding me or because
of all the comic con craziness I do Marvel
and DC videos every week. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
The clip was something right out of a Frank
Miller panel. It was Batman in Gotham on a
rooftop. It’s raining really hard and he
draws the cover off the bat signal. Lightning
Strikes and Superman is there in the air with
glowing red eyes.
Then it cuts to Batman who’s wearing a heavy
armor suit. Like you see in Dark Knight Returns
with glowing white eyes. They don’t speak.
There was an image of Gal Gadot, this hi res
one they released officially while the panel
was going on. She wasn’t in gotham for that
scene. It’s was just like a clip cropped
on one side of the screen and her image on
the other.
It was a little weird. In Hall H if you’ve
never been. It’s got these giant walls.
So studios can roll out extra viewing screens
that kind of wrap around the audience. It’s
just so everyone can see better. There have
always been big screens hanging from the ceiling
in several rows.
But everyone kind of knew something weird
was going on when they rolled out all these
screens. And just to be clear. This wasn’t
a Batman vs Superman panel. It was a 90 minute
Warner Brothers panel during which the talked
about several movies. Batman vs Superman was
just the first one.
If you didn’t see it already I posted the
panel footage. It was super short. Zack Snyder
came out and introduced the clip and the holy
trinity. The funny thing is he told the organizers
not to give them mics. Like he didn’t want
Ben Affleck, Henry Cavill or Gal Gadot to
speak. I laughed a little.
It’s not for any super secret reason. He
probably just thought their presentation would
be more effective if they didn’t speak or
answer questions.
They’re still right in the middle of filming
so they actually had to stop production to
fly the actors in and then fly them right
back right away. Production delays are expensive
because they still have to pay the crew. So
bringing those three actors to comic con for
a two minute Chris Hardwick selfie probably
cost a half a million dollars.
I saw a lot of people commenting that Batman
Ben Affleck that is was taller than Henry
Cavill. I guess feeling like Superman should
be taller. But that’s just actors. Most
actors in general are pretty short. But leading
men, like A-List $150 Million Dollar movie
leading men tend to all be over 6 feet. Minimum.
Ben Affleck is 6’4” so he’s super tall.
Henry Cavill is 6’1”. In the movie I think
they’ll be made to look like equals. Not
counting the extra inches Ben Affleck gets
from the ears on his cowl. But they shortened
those to look more like the Frank Miller versions.
So for those going crazy, when they’re standing
on the ground next to each other. They’ll
be eye to eye. It just makes for better tension.
I’ve already talked a lot about the rumored
story arc. Of their relationship that is,
but since a lot of you guys are new to my
channel I’ll say it again.
The rumors are saying that Batman is pissed
at Superman for being a bull in a china shop.
So Superman is treated by Batman and the other
heroes of the world as an alien. The movie’s
subtitle is Dawn of Justice as in Dawn of
Justice League. So presumably during the course
of events Superman will win Batman’s trust.
This doesn’t really address Gal Gadot’s
role as Wonder Woman or Cyborg or Aquaman.
I know Jason Momoa was rumored for the role.
But nothing has been confirmed. It all ties
in with the idea that Superman’s battle
with Zod destroyed half the planet. Mostly
damage done by those world engines. So the
earth’s heroes call on him to answer for
what he’s done.
That could be what that Bat signal scene was
all about. We saw it out of context, but it
could be the moment when Batman calls Superman
out for the first time. It would definitely
explain why the pictures they showed of both
of them made them look so angry.
Cyborg’s role is also a big mystery as is
the other villains besides Lex Luthor. We
do know that Lexcorp is going to be a tech
company a la Facebook or Google. But since
we don’t know if they’re a software giant
or a hardware giant I can’t tie Cyborg to
them. Cyborg is usually tied to Star Labs
in the comics. During the first Man of Steel
movie, they had a STAR Labs easter egg during
the military base scenes. The logo was just
playing on the screens in the background.
So I’m guessing when the heroes of the world
start to rally against Superman, the military
throws their hat in the ring too, being Cyborg
via military funded Star Labs tech.
The other rumored villains include Morgan
Edge. In the comics he’s a ruthless media
mogul who owns the Daily Planet along with
a bunch of other media companies. He’s like
a Rupert Murdoch figure. Before the new 52
reboot he was also leader of Intergang.
Victor Zasz, who’s just a really freaky
serial killer that tattoos himself every time
he kills someone.
David Cain, who’s another mercenary affiliated
with the league of assassins and Amanda Waller.
Those characters aren’t confirmed. But they’re
the best rumors we’ve heard so far.
If you’ve been watching Arrow then you’ve
seen Cynthia Addai Robinson playing Waller.
On that show she’s leading ARGUS and even
though Bruce Wayne does exist in the tv universe,
she’s never referenced him or anyone else
outside of the characters Arrow is using.
Geoff Johns actually laid the whole Movie
and TV shared universe thing to rest at Comic
Con. He said that TV and Film shall be separate,
for the foreseeable future. That means you
should not expect to see any of the tv actors
in any of the films. Or see any of the storylines
crossover from tv to film.
But Stephen Amell said this really cool thing.
On Television, because they have all these
amazing characters going this fall. You’ll
basically be getting the Justice League every
single week. And I definitely agree. I don’t
mind treating the movies and the tv shows
as alternate universes.
That doesn’t mean it’s always going to
be like that, but don’t plan on it anytime
soon.
There was this funny moment when someone asked
Stephen Amell who he wanted to play Bruce
Wayne in the Arrow verse and he said Robbie
Amell. This was before he was cast as Firestorm
on The Flash. The fact that they’re related
makes watching these shows that much more
meta.
Warner Brothers hasn’t made any indication
it’s going to release the Comic Con clip
although a version of it did leak last week.
So some of may have seen it. But I’ll keep
doing bonus videos for the movie whenever
new things happen. Most of my DC videos are
going to be for the TV Shows this fall. There
are going to be six total. Which is crazy.
There’s Arrow Season 3, then five new shows
including The Flash, Gotham, Constantine,
iZombie and Preacher. Preacher is going to
be on AMC and won’t premiere until 2015.
Gotham is FOX and Constantine is NBC, all
the others are CW.
They haven’t completely ruled out Gotham
crossovers with Arrow and the Flash, but I’m
not expecting it. The showrunner for that
said Gotham existed in an alternate universe
from the other DC Shows.
I know I owe you guys a review of Gotham and
Constantine, but since I’m behind and most
of you haven’t seen those shows. I might
just wait till they actually premiere.
I’ll tell you what though. If you still
want me to do reviews for them leave a comment
saying so and click the like button. If this
video gets more than 2 thousand likes before
Friday. I’ll totally do reviews for both
shows like I did for The Flash.
Right now click here for my Flash Episode
1 Review and click here for the Batman vs
Superman Comic Con Panel.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!